lo que vamos a tratar de hacer en este
vídeo será sumar siete décimos a 13
centésimas pausa en el vídeo y traten de
resolverlo muy bien esto puede ser un
poco intimidante al principio porque
estamos sumando decimos aquí tenemos 7
décimos y le queremos sumar centésimos
aquí tenemos 13 centésimas cómo le hago
para sumar un cierto número de décimos a
un cierto número de centésimos la idea
es expresar siete décimos como un cierto
número de centésimas
como hago eso bueno primero visualicemos
cada una de estas fracciones imaginemos
que este cuadrado es un entero lo hemos
dividido en diez secciones iguales trata
de dibujar esto lo mejor que pude
fíjense que he coloreados siete de estas
secciones iguales en las que he dividido
el entero
esto representa siete décimos y para
trece centésimos podemos dividir el
entero en 100 secciones iguales trate de
dibujar esto a mano así que supongamos
que estas son secciones iguales fíjense
que este es un cuadrado
por 10 así que tenemos 100 cuadrados de
estos y tengo 10 más tres cuadrados
coloreados queremos sumar estos 10
décimos a estos 360 hicimos ahora como
expresamos los décimos en términos de
centésimos visualmente podemos tomar
cada uno de estos décimos y dividirlo en
10 secciones iguales
ahora tenemos dividido este entero en
100 décimos ahora cada uno de los
décimos es un centésimo de modo que
tenemos 10 veces lo que teníamos en el
denominador y también tenemos 10 veces
lo que teníamos en el numerador antes
teníamos siete décimos coloreados ahora
tenemos setenta centésimos coloreados
otra forma de pensar en esto es que
multiplicamos el numerador por 10 y el
denominador por 10 si le hacemos lo
mismo el numerador y el denominador si
lo multiplicamos o lo dividimos por el
mismo número no estamos cambiando el
valor piensen en esto y es entre 10 es
igual a 1 simplemente estamos
multiplicando 1 por 7 decimos eso no va
a cambiar el valor
pero esto como ya lo hemos dicho es
equivalente a 70 sobre 100 esto es
equivalente a 70 centésimos más 360
hicimos ahora estamos sumando centésimos
en los dos casos si tengo 70 de algo y
le sumó 13 de eso mismo y en este caso
es lo mismo son centésimos
voy a tener 83 de ese algo esto va a ser
igual a 70 más trece centésimos cuanto
de 70 más 13 por supuesto que es igual a
83 centésimos
terminamos